look at lizzo I just need to say this to
you I doubt you'll see this below this
stuff isn't healthy it's not cute and it
takes away from your actual Town God has
given you a natural talent to create
good music upbeat uplifting and you're
choosing to drown out your talent by
promoting fatness and yes it is
promoting it when it's all over your
Instagram it's all over your Tick Tock
and that is the thing you are leading
with in every room and I don't care if
your friends around you are hyping you
up I don't care if your boyfriend your
sent boyfriend Hypes you up I don't
really care if the internet Hypes you up
it's not cute and it's sad because you
have so much to offer the world and yet
you are still leading with your fatness
when you should be leading with your
talent